herzlich sondern folge ich fahre leute
heute mit einer besseren lovestory als
bella und edward einer besseren
lovestory als schalke 04 und spiele
verlieren und zwar amg und v8 leute glc
[Musik]
dass man leute da drüben wir sind heute
in gevelsberg leute und dieser karren
ist so aggressiv dass sogar die tauben
zu schauen
sogar die trauben schauen uns zu
die tauben sneak preview krasses
ausdruck 510 ps 7 und newton meter
richtig geil v 8 motor und das ist echt
die motorenbaureihe aus der der auch
stammt das dm 177 aus der bei allen gern
ich alles besteht also die gleichen
baureihe wird auch ein gesetz umgeht die
63 s viertürer mit 630 ps im agg tmc 63
wir können wir kurz reinschauen und man
den motor ein das ist ein so genanntes
heißes v-leute das heißt die beiden
turbolader ist ein biturbo sitzen hier
in der mitte von mv dadurch hat man
richtig krass kompakte bauweise von dem
motors ultra geile konstruktion ja wie
gesagt diese baureihe wird eigentlich in
verschiedenen ausbaustufen in sehr
vielen ags eingesetzt interessanterweise
basiert die auf einem vierzylindermotor
die 214 zusammengepackt ich glaube im
133 war das damals und ja traurigerweise
geht es wieder zu verlieren auch zurück
traurig alter von der skyline zum
bordstein zurück denen macht amg nämlich
kommen wir hier an amerikaner grill
jeder der das 300 sl video gesehen hat
weiß auch woher der begriff panamericana
kommt die seinem mountain graumarkt sehr
sehr oft gewählte farbe aber auch die
beste frau befinden die beste farbe aber
diese scheinwerfer hier wir haben hier
den den mob also mit mbx und innen drin
ist wer die gleichen wie reinschauen
stehen auf 21 zoll würde da
sehr geil die normale bremsanlage die
kleine kammer carbon keramik hans sind
die dafür hat es nicht gereicht
die neue armut in karbon keramik wenn
ihr drüben auf die bremse drauf schaut
carbon keramik ist dann hier halt
einfach ein bremste zu gold orange hier
ist es rot hier sehen wir es v8 biturbo
vom ethik plus schon mal kurz ins
fenster rein sportsitze geil sehr geil
mit mtx dpa in new york ist einfach zu
krass wirklich muss ich sagen
schleichwerbung aber finde ich krass
infotainmentsystem kummer von hinten
also wenn ich das von hinten sehe denke
ich mir so war das ist sowieso ein war
das aber so vollkommen übertrieben groß
aber ob es zum killer wurde der kleinste
ist so wie es ja ja genau ja aber auch
der glc klar gl ist dann geladen und
galaxy gefühl des parks keine richtig
richtig geil gar zwei sachen jetzt für
euch leute wir halten sie heute ganz
kurzen kampf keinen technik vortrag
einfach dass wir schneller zum fahren
kommt das daher weil man videos
verbessern wir die so und ganz wichtig
leute wenn ihr zuhause auch ein auto
habe ein interessantes schnelles krasses
oder einfach mir das auto was ich mich
überfahren soll dann schreib mir auf
instagram erst dann können wir gerne mal
so zusammen kommt wieder nicht zum
beispiel da haben ja auch auf insider
geschrieben
es soll auch schon geil ist das killer
von innen hier erstmal burmester anlage
sehr sehr geil und jetzt guckt euch mal
diesen innenraum anleger das ist doch
einfach nur pornos ihr alcantara auf den
sitzen oder bei mercedes dynamik hier
auch dynamiker carbon im lenkrad ruder
und das finde ich so geil das ist dieser
fahrmodus wählt dabei an gd gar das ist
so geil
mega und du hast aber doch was wurde
könnte klappen an denen geht das offen
zu gehen obwohl 2021 organe aber
ganz alleine kommentare reinschreiben
was jetzt die endgültige lösung ich bin
verwirrt auf jeden fall aber kommt man
hier rein das ist einfach richtig geil
hier leder heads up display dieses
display hatte ich auch so im c 43 meine
aber noch vorm ob aber das ist so geil
aussieht wird für cockpit hier bahn das
ist einfach sexy sexy sexy sexy und
jedes oder mit aufrechten welcher
großaspach logo drauf war
in dem café auf dem tisch liegt dann
läuft
bevor wir jetzt reinspringen los man
heute noch eine ganz wichtige sache und
zwar der soundcheck schön hier ein paar
kosten geht einmal wieder rein schmeißt
den einmal hier einmal anfangen
the [ __ ] is
geil richtig schön asozial roddick das
angeht sehr sehr niedrig so dass wir
auch schon drin in der guten stube hier
schön carbon das schmeckt der bruder
direkten sport plus direkt ins schon
sagen wir fahren also sehr gut da ist
also das start stopp automatik sowieso
deaktiviert ist dann doch ab wann aber
die ist ja auch sicher dieses gericht
dann die erste frage ist immer was
bedeutet es für dich schießt mal los
erzählt einfach mal ja stück freiheit
okay es gibt nichts was ist nach einem
anstrengenden arbeitstag herauszufahren
und einfach mal die achtzylinder
loszulassen er malt insbesondere wenn
man so ein auto hat den mann nur privat
fährt nicht geschäftlich oder jung ja
und alle drei tage mal einmal fährt oder
so nicht täglich damit man sich nicht
dran gewöhnt so ganz verstehen ja ja
genau ja dann macht das sehr schwach sie
dass man wenn man ein steckt jedes mal
ein lächeln das ist nämlich auch das
interessante sache also die sehr viele
leute die solche autos fahren lassen ja
über ein geschäft laufen das ist bei dir
komplett privat ja aber du bist lieb ist
natürlich auch am hassen weil sonst ist
nichts weiter angehen denn sonst gehen
in frage ganz viele leute wollen immer
gerne wissen wenn so leute mit kassen
autos da sind was du deinen job ist oder
so magst du sagen
ja klar wie sie selbständig haben
lebensmittel getränke laden späteren
alles mögliche nebenbei noch immobilien
und
nach einer heimatstadt wo wir kommen aus
der türkei so landwirtschaftlicher okay
so alles alles in allem so ein
eigentlich für mich familie nicht
nebenbei wer im winter tannenbäume
einfach rundherum alles wird geheim
sommer baum
gt3 16 ausschluss sich so groß nicht zu
klein ja die heirat war sehr wichtig
weil ja damals dass ich den geholt habe
falls fahranfänger heckantrieb 10 randy
und sowas nicht so eine gute idee
gewesen ja also leute wenn ihr jetzt
euer erstes auto holt nehmen kein see
werde jetzt alles wiesen auch eine sehr
große familie dass alle reinpassen
beisitzer so geht auch nicht ja und dann
hat der perfekt gepasst innerhalb 510 ps
und nicht auf dem gewicht geht schon
ganz gut
dieses lenkrad das finde ich so krass
das traute ich dieses lenker es ist so
sexy alter alcantara und karbon
beste mischung gibt es ja auch welche in
voller cantara aber so kannst du dann
meistens ja die handelt ja wird das
lenkrad nicht so schnell drücken sie ja
die greifen sich ja unheimlich schon ab
ja das ist wirklich sehr schade bei
dynamic quartal wie man es nennen mag
das dass die sich so schnell abtragen
hart werden
[Musik]
richtig an sozial und dieser amg v8
sound das ist einfach zu krass
[Musik]
ein bisschen aufpassen regen aber sonst
ja sehr geil digger das ist auch so
präsent also klar wird aber was im
innenraum rhein geleitet aber das ist
echt und sehr komfortabel zu sagen ja da
viele sagen ja auch diese sportsitze
sind sehr unbequem ich nicht also ich
habe ich hier eingesetzt die packen
schon auch nicht zu leuten die
kanten kannst eigentlich wangen kommen
auch einsteiger gehe ich nicht muss ich
bin herzlich darum dass alles gut aber
ja also die packen schon zu muss man
sagen aber voll komfortabel bis jetzt
auf dem harten fahrwerk gerade wir
können an komfort gelegt werden leute
auf sogar auf harten kämpfen ist das so
und relaxed ihr alter ist so relax sag
mal sagen wie alt bist du ich bin 19 19
dieses jahr
bruder weil leute warum machen wir also
insel vom
30 also da wirken wie 30 19 bist du
krank leute wir sind es nicht und wir
tun jetzt mache aber die fenster runter
wenn sich jetzt jetzt weiß jetzt
[Musik]
apa
ok jetzt du hast einen sitzer
eingespeichert naja eigentlich mal
bisschen runter
doch machen wir den gang entlang gericht
angriffe schönes heads up display der
dieses lenkrad ist wirklich einfach eine
absolute schönheit leute unfassbar muss
also schreibt man gerne die kommentare
wenn ihr eins im kopf hab was ihr
persönlich schöner findet aber das ist
einfach
fast alles
[Musik]
und dann kriegt seitdem wackelt aus dem
fahrersitz
geiles waren gemeinsam vor vier jahren
auch gas aber jetzt vom beifahrersitz
aus ist
eine hinter das können wir auch nicht
haben ja heute alles fordern können wir
ja heuer klar okay sollte man kann ein
staat
die
fußabdrücke ich nicht drauf jetzt gas
richtig drauf aber nicht offen auf und
hier
[Musik]
sowas haben jetzt hier ein gezimmert
44 41 42 nasser straße drei leute drin
halb voller tank das ist schon das ist
schon alles was man sagen das ist ja
immer so angeben mit 38 hatte also 38 39
hier ist
jacke leider ging das auch der weg via
mit hier so wies einen gewissen nebel
sinnvoll der bremse
das ist eine traktionskontrolle sport
wieder der 42 mal so schlecht nach
kastels über langsam
echt hart genug
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
so leicht autobahn einmal volles
register durch la la
[Musik]
diese gangwechsel hart
und wenn dieser vorarbeiten 3d
also richtig richtig geil muss ich sagen
die sonne verschwindet da die gpus
können beide nicht mehr bei dem
schwachen licht faust darauf vielen dank
fürs dabei sein der kurs geht raus an
dich leute und jetzt kommen wir zur
bewertung von diesem wunderschönen
reisen und die bewertung beginnt
natürlich wie immer ihr wisst es bereits
mit dem aussehen meine sehr vielen damen
und herren der glc 63 es macht einen
sehr sehr imposanten eindruck hat aber
so ein paar details beispielsweise das
heck die ich nicht übermäßig gelungen
finden weswegen in neun von zehn nicht
angebracht ist acht von zehn ist fährt
die beschleunigung fühlt sich nicht nur
im auto brutal an sondern dies auch auf
dem papier richtig stark 3,8 sekunden
von null auf hundert macht der glc coupé
als 63 ist das ist richtig richtig gut
deswegen auch hier starke acht von zehn
bei der cool das hatte ich den wagen
eigentlich bei neun von zehn gesehen
aber da muss ich diesen klassischen amg
abzugeben ich hoffe ihr seht es mir nach
leute ist sieht man einfach ich weiß
auch nicht warum heutzutage so oft und
nun überall gefühlt plus ag ist nicht
immer besonders herausragend als modell
an sich wie es zum beispiel der rs6 als
der vertreter von dem power comics ist
deswegen acht von zehn sehr fair in der
spaß dann kommen wir damit auf 24 von 30
punkten und auf platz zehn beim punkt
praktikabilität wird sich gerade ein
bisschen lachen leute weil eigentlich
ist der gt als coupé 63 essen voll ab so
das auto aber der ist wirklich praktisch
man man sitzt gut drin man hat einen
kofferraum mit einer sehr schönen weit
öffnenden heckklappe plus man kann sogar
hinten in dem modell was wir in dem
video hatten sogar über das luftfahrwerk
an der hinterachse den wagen absenken
das heißt man kann dann quasi noch
einfacher beladen die man das auto erst
mal runter fährt sehr praktisch acht von
zehn preis gleich so finde ich ehrlich
gesagt bei dem wagen nicht so überragend
startet der wagen wir in dem video
gesehen haben kostet fast 140.000 euro
da kann auch das affengeil lenker nicht
hinwegtäuschen dass das nur sechs von
zehn sein kann willkommen vor hingegen
ist barbara sich leute das kann ich euch
sagen ja ich in dem video gesehen ich
war wirklich wirklich überrascht wie
komfortabel dieses auto viel viel
komfortabler zum beispiel als seine
mitbewerber wie der x4 competition echt
nur sehr starke leistung muss man sagen
acht von zehn ergibt in der alltagswelt
22 von 30 punkten und einen sehr sehr
starken fünften platz von der
insbesondere der gesamtwertung muss sich
dieser wahl für die straße gar nicht
verstecken 46 von 60 punkten
reicht für platz 4 von bisher 18
getesteten autos unter dem strich
richtig geile kiste einfach schön dass
amg v8 gebrabbel das ist einfach nice
wenn jetzt eine bewertung über das
anders sieht oder fieber gehabt dann
schreibt man das gerne in die kommentare
reichen leute ich bin richtig heiß auf
das nächste video nächsten sonntag ist
eure augen und bis dann noch gut